- We will be judging everything based off
their OWL equivalency level.
(gentle music)
- Harry Potter is everything.
- He's my one true love.
- Harry Potter's so much more than just
a cool thing, it's just
a way of life.
- Are they supposed to be frogs?
They're almost frogs.
- Please tell me these
aren't actually cockroaches.
- I mean, I'm into it.
- I'm gonna get the most
cockroach looking one.
- It's fudgey, it's sweet.
- It's like two different
types of chocolate
or is that caramel?
- Wizarding world's version of a turtle.
- If real cockroaches tasted like this,
I could live off cockroaches.
- The (beep) is this?
- This is not a chocolate frog.
- This is pretty thick.
- Well, who do you think
would be eating this?
- Hufflepuffs, to be honest.
- Oh, God, here it goes.
- It's good.
- It's so much sugar.
- It's like slimy, but sweet slimy.
- If I had a spoon,
(laughs) this would be a good dessert.
- It looks like a muggle
but tastes like magic.
- Chocolate frog's ugly
cousin, peppermint toads.
- Everything in the Wizarding world so far
has been very mushy (laughs).
- Oh my God, it smells really minty.
- It's really sweet and really
thick.
- [Man] It's gross.
- This is (beep) weird.
This tastes like toothpaste.
- It's basically the peppermint filling
from a peppermint patty.
- I love the frog, but--
- Yeah, it's cute to look at.
- [Man] It is dense.
- First year at Hogwarts,
I'm eating these all day.
- (gasps) Droobles Best
Blowing Bubblegum. Cool!
- It's a little stickier than a gumball.
- It's so chewy. Why?
- It tastes like we're chewing on gum
that someone already chewed on.
- I actually kind of like this
harder, thicker gum texture.
- There's not much of a flavor,
so I guess that would last all day.
- Mmm, blueberry, uh--
- Grape?
- [Man] Magic.
- It does lose its flavor really quickly.
- Yeah, it's gone.
I can feel the flavor just
dripping into my throat.
- It's not a bubble.
- That's the first bubble I've ever blown!
(chuckles)
- That was awesome.
- You can make candies taste like you read
in the books, but you
can't make 'em magic.
- Any chance to bring the HP world to life
is okay by me.
- I think I've just gotten an idea for
next date night with my wife.
Except I'm definitely gonna
make a chocolate frog.